Oh
surge arresters come one of the founders
of info it's in the door come we do is
always filmmakers films online a sherry
fifty percent of revenue found national
advertisers old cairo the costs
streaming encoding life's work that's
the general idea though and you're
teaming up with demon are big managers
work on the other party like to like to
go out and send the message job there's
a place for independent operators in all
the ways on the tech guy writes look
like my hand to the challenge of being
able to stream a lot of my beach
liabilities and my name is david brings
a good angle and white rings producing
it so in the three of us or we know
enough to be dangerous we don't know
what probably not letting show their
works at best lamb